begim welcome uh to the show today it
felt like an easier Day at the Office uh
For You especially because of this crazy
moment that happened in the first five
moves she actually took on B4 tell us
about this preparation did you know that
Bishop days B4 is just
losing uh I knew that
because like people don't take on before
and then nobody takes on before nobody
actually took
on yeah that's like I know Queen A4
Knight E5 I should be winning but after
Rook B8 I had to just sit down and like
understand that after C5 I'm not sure if
it's the strongest move but I didn't see
anything like any defense for her I have
a feeling she thought after Rook B8 if I
take on
C6 uh she's having a like fine position
if I don't then she's going back to
Bishop E7 and I have a feeling she just
missed C5 I had no clue after Bishop
like B before I had no clue what was
going on C5 is just winning yes C5 is
the key move and the idea being that you
can also drop back with the Knight to D3
to catch uh the bishop like that so
that's a problem for her position what
did you feel she missed was it this C5
is that what
you C5 I didn't see Rook B8 I didn't see
anything I was like wait they don't play
like this so then I had to figure out C5
and then after that I'm just winning
absolutely and um there were some
chances along the way did feel like
maybe she was getting some compensation
at this point but you found this idea of
a bishop to A3 and our question is what
if she would have played
A5 and this was something that Yu was
trying to make work as
well yeah I thought that was interesting
move I was uh thinking of Bishop B2 yes
if A4 Bishop A3 back right that was was
my idea because I'm threatening a A3
myself so I thought uh Pawn on A4 could
be better for me or for her and if she
that was my idea and if she goes it's
still complicated right Rook takes B8 A3
and Knight to B3 how did you assess this
one it seems like this was maybe her
only chance to go into this position
yeah I mean okay I'm piss up I will
figure out
right
d392 yeah yeah figure it out well um
after that I cannot calculate everything
so I just thought position should be all
right yeah well after that she played
Bishop takes A3 and you never let go of
uh the decisive Advantage another great
Victory another step towards that
National Championship are you starting
to think about that or you're still
taking it one game at a
time yeah I'm taking one game at a time
it's still two rounds it's you know it's
hard hard to predict anything so I'll
just try uh to blow my games guys any
questions yeah quick question for you
bam first of all our congratulations
really it's uh phenomenal to come into
studio and day after day to see you and
Carissa winning and matching one another
it's absolutely extraordinary uh
Christian is very very proud of you very
proud of your success and I just wanted
to ask you how grateful are you to your
coach Christian for your outstanding
result well you know if he didn't invite
me to us I wouldn't even have this
results so I'm I'm forever grateful and
he did a great job good point and for
this tournament in
particular oh yeah sir I know where are
you
going just asking the S questions stop
it no it's really it it's really is
extraordinary we just had an interview
with Arena where she says two players
are in great form did you come into this
uh tournament feeling that you were
ready to play such a successful event
how how do you do it no I of course I
had no clue I was doing my school and
trying to do as much chess as possible
you know I I work as well so I didn't
really uh put all of me to prepare for
this tournament it's just like uh at
some I didn't start as you can see in my
games like I didn't start well I had
some shaky games so at some point I just
started to score and feel confident
better about my chess I guess U we'll
see still to runs everything can happen
it's very early to assess all right
thank you bam and uh keep up the good
work we'll see you tomorrow thank you
guys absolutely and what's happening
with Carissa